[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
machine gun kelly and megan fox's
romance is still going strong as they
celebrate the rapper's 31st birthday
and good friends kourtney kardashian and
travis barker were by their side to ring
in the special occasion
i love it kelly took to his instagram
stories sharing
several videos from his birthday dinner
where a couple of friends had gathered
to celebrate
in one clip the musician and actress
share a sweet kiss
before he blows out the candles on his
pink and black cake
captioning the video dream big
happy birthday
[Music]
[Applause]
fox shared her own birthday tribute
thursday night
posting a mirror selfie of the love
birds and captioning the post
happy birthday blonde angel baby i don't
want to lose that
feeling mgk continued to celebrate
posting more photos of himself enjoying
the night out alongside megan courtney
and travis
the rapper captioned the birthday post
i'll grow up next summer
sin seriously birthday boy it's hard to
top that one man
back in march a source told et that the
couples have had double date nights
many times and are all good friends
quote they have a great time when they
hang out as couples and it's very
natural
easy and fun the source adds that they
have a lot of shared interests like
music
self-care practices and more courtney
and travis are super into each other and
megan and machine gun kelly are so in
love
so it's nice for both couples to spend
time with like-minded people
this is such a dream come true
you